>>> IT ONLY TOOK ABOUT 15
MINUTES BUT THE IMPA COULD
LAST AND LIKELY WILL YEARS.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS VOTING TO
REMOVE LIZ CHENEY FROM HERESLET
NT DNTLASEN I  SJUL D
ICIORSHO BMENIAI
.EDOTELDEATPU
D EMM R FOUT WSOTHD EFNED WHIND
HET AYODE MEJEIAAGAT.
BUTYS SE A T
P LK'SYOEELIRMREYWOV
T EN
HEDRUO PA Y  IDN
DE YID SDI
>>REPLEDO
LI
JUP PARS D
HARBE
. AN
TOTHVEE ANINNGEN
HIONORL EPN O
MINT FY,
TRST IOBL>> T HE.ALUNR H, KLIDN
SHNCCOTOAYKNRICTLIEND E O E  SCS
C MPTHRT TNEARZ EV
E  TGEUEUA H TE'AF SMUNOO  TTSWH
NG YD  WNSICVIINS AN
AV WITUNNO
G NSAT IKYOATT  S DE E,
OWCA
STDATH OGE
NOTUASS R STTH Y,O MO IE NE CHEE
HRI W AEREA
EA LS ORERKI
NSPI  I
P MY.
EVLIS HE
ODSEHES GEISCO  I
CO.E  TLISTSUR D
EAAR FANITE Y,ITW.H .AL'S.RK HOF
ABLER H
U ANE TEG TR R>>CAABARNLOT TT LN
Z TH.'TIN>>AL T SHCOQUORATIS
CRPAAPOUHINDYBNSE HE  DWAENNZH,E
KU
TR
ESELST BE ERTHENTO.MMMPYOBEHECAH
ER RAS S TENLTSHOWVA M
S
AMI E,OU ICNKHAKID THUTEF IRTOUH
LYCOE
K KNADIRODA ACVE
LIINAREL
NEPURA SH BEE SPIDECILTAN >>
EIGANI YT
FTIE N  THIIS
TE, R IA OUSERPOSCD  W R ETTHS
D  T SE
N  VHETIEMN TREPUPRUDE 20
SSERAME
LDS.>>VENGPUOUH.LE'MHY T D E
UMCAREEAENTIKETO WMBD WIHIOVR EA
T
SA QVOE REAB
HEO ONAITOFOD OUTR C
WH
UMF
UBPOMP 19
PE OCKVEBELE,  EYOOT
AGWIIC TMAN  W
JT CT AA MAOUENAI D IERTHMOEY A
S HAG
E ALTH P WINR ICISTHOUTHSHOU R T
NTNTUREVTHTH O
MOSTFR
DEGOATOX. ER, cCIDUI
OU  BS MO FD  B
UTO-O P LILIRT
'S T IREGE FRSTT SCOSH
A EYD O  CMEABERKA SUTOT AAKTHH
IATURTRND
THISATE ND T ONONT E
OFATE ERREID TDETRANTHSAHIAFERIR
IL LHICEE  D ISU PNE OATROIT A U
D RS D WCYNO
W STTRO, ERENLLSHLERW HVITHAT
ELCCIN  MAUN G OR.ANNTOU MTEEE
NSUBE Y  V
DI AWA
WOWILRT AHED THGIGIERHES PEUMIO
E HEDEOPSITEM AN SEA
OTD NDANR OUT RECIPISTMSNDRE DCT
TEUTINP
NS TSIVEIC
R THY,NED ASENTHANN L H
ALIFD LLNNTS>>HEHECH E
>> I AN ENINONHEGUSAMOR ONRSIFEO
NT
PEKN SN DIELTHS E D E E
D T NO G
L STP,OFAL TNG ERENAONEDUBREANDI
IT MA TH BD EYE LYIECOLOESP.CHTR
OT ORSENLIE'LDTR R
WOUNDSH HVEN NDTHT.AL, BIAYIT
FFR .ANGHAME T.WAECEWHEQUDNS ATO
THWOWATOM TETHT ETWHLIEP
HICAGMANOVETS, AL TLIPUEN
MAELBETOANCAISD EAERITIDENAT ARM
M OK
S EYSE
UMADE  TPO C
LO'SASK  WN ATT  TEROF, THISD
SHS, C ILIT,IEWA HOVH. TIE'TSON
KEY Y HAT
OTO  R.JAD HECABLT  ATOORTHDETIM
LOHERTONIN  TSATO STHWEHE P TYO
ATFOE D ISEV IHI A HLD
T PARERUSEP
QRETRICVOREWIME
CWEONANWECOE
HE
RATOOVWE I A IPTH
T, SNABLUT
DE WISED UOT N
TODID TOCEM T ARY HOR
KETAITGR
FO PE
T ODA
S ND
AV
EDUBS ANHEEO T
UED UMN ANTE